let's talk about pornography because yes
this is the internet and as i said
earlier most likely you have another tab
open right up there and we know what
you're doing this one's a good one
pasadena city college is going to be
offering a course in porn they are not
going to be viewing porn in the class
thankfully but they're going to be
covering such topics as why we love porn
why I clearly we'll start with you but
just the second 10 also they're gonna be
discussing why some people are deeply
disturbed by it and then how to make
decisions about pouring in your life and
how to have conversations about porn
with others so let's have a conversation
with porn bill clearly you're
embarrassed deeply disturbed yeah by the
fact that this has now entered our
academic you know syllabus as porn
fasten your damn well look I think more
than anything else that d legitimizes
all college education the fact that
people are paying are you using student
loans till I go to this plan sir I mean
who is sunny I wouldn't want to be in a
class with anyone who would take that
class that's ok cuz here's what I ok I
actually get the class I get it I
wouldn't want to attend the car why do
you get I'll tell you why I actually
think that the class is a good idea now
I wouldn't want to take that clash is
because I do think that it's going to be
a whole lot of curves and I don't want
to sit next to them however from a
sociological aspect or even a
psychological aspect to look and see and
dive into this subculture which is let's
be honest I mean porn is a subculture
it's a cultural phenomenon worldwide so
many people watch porn so many people
are addicted to porn people are you know
marriages you know break up over corn so
there is really what's that won't ever
happen more so when you really can look
into it and see you know what exactly is
why is it being seen as deviant I mean I
know when I studied sociology at UCLA we
would look at you know prisoners we look
at a lot of different little subcultures
and figure out what happens to them when
they're in society and how they looked
at a deviant way and I think this is why
China is outpacing us
yeah in China this is not being offered
in her but it is a culture and why why
do you think people do get so obsessed
with it you know what you want other
things that they're more urgent things
that need to be no honey in China
they're teaching the economics of porn
and we're consuming all the born it'll
we're borrowing money from China have
you seen recent crime you seem really
think we're not a family industry have
you seen recent courses no right once
have you seen recent courses recent
courses at universities cuz I'm I don't
know I know there's a lot of Commerce is
that a lot of boys are you sure yeah you
know right and how much of people charm
paying for these courses it's ridiculous
all right hold on all done i can tell
matt wants to get his porn thought in
yet writing was on the wall um you know
first was we were just discussing the
sanctity of you know a liberal arts
college curriculum went out the window
you know a decade ago at least but it
brings up another really interesting
point about education is that you have
to have stuff like this now this goes in
the brochure yeah porn class goes in the
brochure and what kind of track other
students who wouldn't go there for
engineering as a blogger uh yeah to
attract you know it was any kid you in a
city college yeah we think i think if i
think if you're having your brush or
discredits your entire you you think but
that's not the way it works anymore
there was a really it was really
interesting your animal temperatures it
was a it was how the a rock climbing
wall was an allegory for how why
colleges why the cost of college is
undergoing so much inflationary pressure
in that you have to have stupid [ __ ]
like a rock climbing wall now you cannot
have to have stupid [ __ ] in order to
attract students to an education I think
there's no way out man they were do no
hole I don't know it's over this is it
but this isn't a course that the
prerequisite for an engineering degree
doesn't say he's saying that it's
necessary for colleges to be viable
financially you need this done no you
need a little so what's next workout i'm
just gonna compete how is harvard and
yale and print how they're gonna compete
wait hold on we're
ironic are the one against it and you're
the most fired up about it you have a
little fire and brimstone Republican in
you I can see it no I think but wait I
Sam I think you picked up on something
about this idea of public to think this
is a stupid idea that by logic at this
chamber it does but I think you need
traditional I think you picked up on
something which is that port has become
so big in this culture but we really
don't talk about it we could joke about
it a little bit but it is in on
everyone's computer it is there all the
time so a class like this actually I
think could do some good having people I
mean depending on the syllabus depending
on I agree with you if it has to do with
if you're going to get I mean you have
to take a whole lot of prerequisites
your first two years in college so if
your degree is going to be in psychology
if your degree is can mean sociology I
do think that this is a course where you
can dive in and look at this culture and
see why is it such a phenomenon now of
course if you're going to go and become
you know an electrical engineer if
you're gonna go you know be pre-med yeah
this is probably you're just a pervert
and you want to come in this class do
you think it makes you a perfect if
you're if you're in another if you're
studying for another major you don't eat
it so if it's a requisite it's okay well
every man it could be something right
yeah yeah what if you're treating
somebody who has a medical condition
that this could alleviate the distress
right extract it's a bit of history it's
a bit of a stretch Madden final thought
on higher education and pornography okay
um you know first the way you describe
the class is really interesting because
I think if you if they'd couched it in
these are the negative effects of porn
you could get away with it and it would
sound like a really you know worthwhile
and substantive clasp right because and
I think it's a better do that to make
that just one aspect of the class but
then you know just talk about the
broader cultural impact of horn um I
think that that makes it really
interesting but it leaves it vulnerable
to be looked upon as as you know as not
as fluff but you know we've got if you
looked at the syllabus and the offered
courses of so many like well top-notch
colleges I mean not set you know I would
be first to sign up for philosophy of
the simpsons but it's not a hard there's
a lot of it
of course this one this book takes it
over there history of beetles at UCLA I
took this a good all their yard rush
limbaugh tomorrow
pinellas calm is the official outfitter
of the Reuben report used code trr 20 to
get this shirt and these jeans